the gorgeous sun-drenched world of luca
is overflowing with pixar easter eggs
from pizza planet trucks to luxo balls
deep sea finding nemo references and hat
tips to up
yipikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video i'm revealing over 80 easter eggs
and crucial details plus the
post-credits scene you might have missed
in lucca
some mild spoilers ahead so take care
italian food
features heavily in lucca from the
enormous sandwiches that town bully er
cole enjoys to the pasta eating section
of the portoroso cup
however pixar's nod to its legendary
pizza planet truck is much harder to
find
so watch carefully during the final part
of the bicycle race towards the end of
the movie and it appears very briefly
just behind
erkole as he's chasing luca and alberto
down the cobbled streets
another tricky to spot regular pixar
easter egg is the famous luxo ball
look out for the balls signature yellow
red and blue colours during an aerial
shot of the bicycle race
another recurring pixar easter egg a113
appears on the train ticket that alberto
gives to luca so he can go to school in
genoa
the appearance of a113 and pixar's films
is a tribute to the classroom at
california institute of the arts where
many of the studio's animators studied
and the number on the carriage that look
aboard 1200 pa
is a reference to the address of pixar's
headquarters 1200 park avenue emeryville
and the number on the front of the train
94608
is a studio zip code hidden in one of
the signs for soft drinks in the town is
a deep cut reference to one of pixar's
most beloved films
up this poster on a side street of the
main square has an ad for a cherry
flavored drink with various bottle caps
on the right for other flavors
it's a little difficult to see but the
purple coloured cap is a nod to the
grape soda pin that ellie gave carl when
they were kids in up
you and me we're in a club now the art
of luca book shows a design was made for
a bottle cap
labelled over the italian word for grape
confirming this is indeed a reference to
up during one of luca's stream sequences
as he soars through the air on a
leonardo da vinci flying machine below
him is the famous fictional wooden
marionette pinocchio together with the
cat and fox from the original italian
book which many decades later was
adapted for disney's animated movie
and there's another pinocchio reference
in the song elgato ella volpe the cat
and the fox
which plays as alberto and luca build
another homemade vespa
the cat in the fox references the two
rogues from the story of pinocchio and
director enrique casaroza chose the song
not
only for its playful and fun feel but
also because he sees similarities
between luca and alberto and the cat and
the fox and how each pair gets into
trouble together
there's also a pinocchio figurine in
julia's bedroom and the story of the
famous wooden puppet who eventually
becomes a real human boy
also has some parallels with luca's
story as he can transform from a sea
monster into a human
another intriguing easter egg i spotted
in julia's bedroom
is a record cover for an artist called
nicolo pitera
a reference to nick patera who's an
animator for pixar
and also one of the voices in the triple
dank gum jingle from inside out
triple then gun will make you smile
nick peter also has his own youtube
channel where he covers numerous songs
including many from disney's musicals
and remember me from pixar's coco
in julia's bedroom there's a cute donald
duck toy and some of these cloud
formations that appear in one of luca's
dream sequences look like hidden mickeys
and another disney reference springs up
on one of the film posters in the town
square
for the 1954 movie twenty thousand
leagues under the sea
the underwater adventure adapted from
the book by jule verne
vern was also briefly referenced in
another pixar creature feature
monsters inc via a poster in a parisian
room that mike sully and boo fall into
there's also a fun fictional movie
poster for a film called ataco del
mostro marino
attack of the sea monster which features
a fearsome creature that looks a lot
like
uncle ugo the poster has a hilarious
b-movie vibe from the 50s to 60s era
when luke is set and recalls films such
as attack of the crab monsters and
creature from the black lagoon
in contrast to the much more appealing
look of luca and alberto sea monsters
uncle ugo was designed to be as scary
and weird looking as possible for a
disney film so that luca would dread the
idea of having to go and live with him
in the trench
casa rosa said that ugo is based on the
very strange creatures found in the deep
and to me with his bioluminescent law he
looks like a cross between an angle of
fish like the one we saw in finding nemo
and the barrel eye another weird looking
real-life fish that has transparent
flesh around its upper half so you can
see inside it
similar to uncle ugo by the way in an
interesting bit of casting
ugo is voiced by sasha baron cohen
perhaps best known for the borat movies
and the odd tone he uses adds to the
uncomfortable effect that ugo has on
luca
hello
luca i need you to punch his heart luca
also tips its hat to finding nemo via
the diving helmet both alberto
luca were which is the same design as
the one in philip sherman's fish tank
where nemo ends up in his movie
lucas filmmakers also had some fun with
the surnames of the various sea monsters
in the movie
so luca's name pagoda is italian for
hermit crab
reflecting his sheltered life at the
beginning of the film and the reluctance
of his parents to let him venture above
the surface
on top of that it also foreshadows how
luca will eventually come out of his
shell and reveal his true self as well
as the fact that ultimately he'll be
comfortable living in different
surroundings than he grew up in
alberto's son named scorfano is italian
for scorpion fish
and the branzino family who luca's mum
keeps mentioning get their name from the
italian word for sea bass
let's see bianca brazino do that and a
hint to the secret that these two old
ladies are actually sea monsters it's
their surname at augusta which is
italian for lobster
oh and i also like the little detail
that the goat fish that luca shepherds
actually bleat just like a land goat
direct enrico casa rosa has a couple of
voice cameos in lucca
he's the voice of the fisherman who sets
up the film's stupido running joke when
alberto and luca overhear him
shouting to a speeding boat what's wrong
with you stupidor
he's also the card player who yells
scrubber when he wins
for those unfamiliar that's a popular
card game played with an italian deck of
cards
you can see one of those designs close
up on the card that alberto tries to
steal at the beginning of the movie on
which
luca later finds and the reverse of the
card with its picture of a town in the
top half reflected in the lower half
is a nice detail referencing the
underwater civilization beneath the sea
right by puerto rosso when luca and
alberto meet julia's father massimo for
the first time they discover he has a
particularly keen
interest in hunting sea monsters the
pictures pinned to his wall are a nod to
the various legends that pixar's
filmmakers researched for the movie
from old renaissance maps to legends of
japanese dragons and serpents
one particular legend from the town of
talaro in the liguria region
tells the giant octopus that one night
climbed out of the sea and rang the
church bells to warn the inhabitants of
an attack by pirates
and in lucca there are octopus door
knobs as well as an octopus plaque
near the town square which reference
similar ones from the town of toledo
that pay
tribute to the legendary octopus and
octopuses with their ability to
camouflage themselves and change the way
they look
also inspired the filmmakers for how
lucas sea monsters could quickly
transform into humans
true to luca's nostalgic feel and
setting there are many easter eggs the
italian post-war golden age of cinema
there's the poster of la strada the
oscar-winning drama by fellini
and the name of the boat gel seminar is
the name of the protagonist in that
movie
casa rosa also took inspiration from
another fellini film e vitaloni for the
final scene of luca
the design of the train that arrives to
take luka away and how the scene is shot
with luka looking back to alberto who
runs after him as the train departs
pays homage to the ending of fellini's
film and if you're wondering what that
black and white photo is that alberto
looks at just before he and luca attempt
their first ride down the island slope
it's of the lead actor marcelo
mastroyani from the oscar-winning comedy
drama divorce italian style
and fun fact kiara his daughter with
actress catherine denerve
lends her voice to luca's mum for the
film's french dubbed version
and another film starring marcelo
mastroyani also pops up in the movie
appropriately enough the film playing on
the tv while julia and luca are sneaking
across the rooftops is the 1958
acclaimed italian heist movie
big deal on madonna street another
poster is for the oscar-winning roman
holiday a hollywood romantic comedy set
in rome and starring gregory peck and
audrey hepburn
various signs in the town also pay
homage to other acclaimed italian
artists the vicolo di sika references
the neorealist director vittorio de sica
who directed classics such as the
bicycle thief the piazza calvino is a
nod to italian writer italo calvino and
julia massimo's surname
valdo is a shout out to the name of a
short story collection penned by calvino
and the bar pitaloga may be a reference
to the italian film producer stefano
pitoluga who began his career as a
cinema owner in casaroza's hometown of
genoa
there's also what looks like a fake
poster which translates as a summer to
remember so i think this post is a fun
reference to how this movie is the story
of a summer that luca alberton julia
will never forget
prior to directing luca enrico casaroza
was best known for his oscar-nominated
short film la luna and the frequent
lunar imagery in this movie together
with julia and luca's fascination with
astronomy feel like a hat tip to the
acclaimed short
plus julia's father massimo also has a
similar character design and thick heavy
moustache as the father in the short
film
and this boy drawing stars in the end
credits is the boy from la luna
an in joke that some coffee lovers might
have spotted is the bar sign lataza
referencing not only the popular italian
brand of coffee lavazza but also the
fact that lataza means cup in italian
and i couldn't help but chuckle at all
the holy cheese variations that julia
comes up with whenever something
surprises her
santa gorgonzola
for the animation style of lucca
casaroza wanted to go with a more
cartoonish somewhat exaggerated look
that took inspiration from both looney
tunes and miyazaki's films such as the
castle of caliosterol
and you can see these influences in
scenes such as where alberto tries to
ride his homemade vesper for the first
time and after it falls apart he ends up
running down the hill spinning his legs
so fast that extra limbs appear
something you can also see in this scene
from the castle of caliostro
and there's a looney tunes inspired
moment when luke has thrown off his bike
after breaking suddenly and the halo of
fish swimming around its head
is a suitably aquatic take on the
circling birdies effect
often seen in cartoons interestingly
portorozzo is a mashup of the names of
several towns on the northwest coast of
italy where lucas directors spend his
own childhood
and according to casaroza a wonderful
extra reason to name the town that was
miyazaki's film por coroso
there are some intriguing comparisons
between luca and disney's little mermaid
like ariel luca wants to explore
land-based life above the surface and
both are told not to go
by their parents also like ariel alberto
collects
objects from the human world and both
films have some amusing moments with
forks with the sea creatures not
properly understanding their human use
and coincidentally or perhaps not jacob
tremblay who voices luca
will also be the voice of flounder in
disney's upcoming live-action version of
the little mermaid
when you get to the end of the movie
make sure to sit through the credits as
a humorous post-credits scene which
features the return of uncle ugo
this time he's back in his original
habitat talking to what appears to be
one of lucas goat fish about how great
it is to live in the deep it's away from
the hustle and bustle
all the stuff that you don't want ooga
also eats a piece of whale carcass a
call back to how he described living in
the deep earlier in the movie
well carcass i'm curious to see how luca
fits in with the pixar theory first put
forward by john negroni who also has a
youtube channel
and that theory posits that after the
events of wally animals evolved over
time into the monsters from monsters inc
in lucca we can see there's a species of
sea creature in the 1950s that already
has the ability to rapidly change into
and out of human form
if you've got any ideas be sure to leave
them in the comments below and if you
want to find out how pixar's previous
movie soul essentially confirmed many
aspects of the pixar theory tap here to
watch my video on that or follow the
link in the video description
and if like me you really enjoyed the
gorgeous animation of luca you'll want
to check out the art of luca book with
amazing concept art from the movie
i'll add a link where you can get a copy
in the description below
so what were your favorite moments in
easter eggs in lucca
if you enjoyed this don't forget to like
and subscribe and you can tap left for
my next pixar video or tat right for
something else you're sure to like
thanks for watching and see you next
time yupikai movie lovers